[background noises]
[music playing]
[printer printing]
Some people gave a
tip to Public Citizen,
a Washington D.C.-based
non-profit organization,
about what appeared
to be some shady
water deals going on in
Central Valley of California.
The first thing I
did was I looked
up the Kern Water Bank online.
Google was in its early years--
more or less, 2003.
Well, it turns out it's
largely controlled by something
called "Roll International."
And when I called
their headquarters
and asked to speak to a
public relations person,
they said they didn't have one.
And I said, "Well, to
whom should I address
any research questions?"
They said, "We don't give
information to the public.
We suggest you don't
research us," and hung up.
So I drive down to
Bakersfield and then followed
the directions out
to the address,
and I'm a little bit confused
because the sign outside says
"Paramount Farming Company"--
not "Kern Water Bank Authority."
Walk in the front door and
ask a receptionist, "Is--
the Kern Water Bank, do you
know where that office is?"
"Oh, yeah.
They're just down
the hall," they said.
It's like, "OK."
The Kern Water Bank is this
supposedly public entity,
and the members are a number
of different water districts--
water agencies, water
storage districts, and also
a private company
called "Westside
Mutual Water Company, LLC."
And I remember asking,
"Who are they?"
"Well, they're landowners."
"Well, what land do they own?"
"Well, they represent
their own land."
They didn't want to
mention the name "Paramount
Farming," which was
notable considering
where we were sitting--
which was inside
Paramount's office building.
It seemed as if this is a
case of extremely valuable
public property, an essential
element of the state
public water system,
which had essentially
been given to a very
wealthy private company--
but really just one landowner,
one corporate farmer.
[music playing]